Lego Star Wars
Yay, finally, you guys have been begging me to play this for weeks and weeks and weeks
So here we are. It's actually Marzia's favorite game, but I just want to get this done
Okay. I mean I love this game and we're gonna play it now
Alright so, I'll pick a new game. Real Marzia: What are you doing? Marzia!
I'm just. Real Marzia: This is my favorite game I know it's your favorite game. Are you playing it without me?
No, I was I was setting it up. Oh my god! No I was setting it up for us to play it Are we playing it together?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're playing it together. Is it a surprise? Yeah it's a surprise! Your favorite game!
Oh my god! Oh my god yes! C'mon *Felix dies inside*
Do you like my lipstick? Yeah May I say you look so good togay
I'm so excited to be playing this today with my girl, my future wife
This is my favorite game. This is your favorite game.
Do you like that I re-colored my hair again?
Yeah, you look beautiful.
I look like I used to.
And you're so much taller
When we first played Lego That's right!
It's the first game we played together. We played this first game...
(perfect Italian accent) Pewds, why you have be so horrible to me
Your face is so big
Alright, you're gonna be Quia-gon. No I'm Quia-gon
Hello there. Don't you know who that is
Know qui gong gym. I didn't think Lego Star Wars is so hard
I don't know what's happening
It's okay. It's even more difficult cause I can't hear it
You play games on mute? Yeah.
That explains why it's so annoying to edit and the sound is always wrong
Okay, all right you don't edit my video
Brad is always telling me. Oh, he tells you okay. That makes- Wait, what else is Brad tell you?
He said that you have very small... legs
That is why you are always so short. I'm taller than you.
When does this happen in the movie? I don't know
What is happening? I have no idea. I thought I knew Star Wars
Doesn't it start on a big ship? and they do the-
Yeah master destroyers "master destroyers" tell me I love it why you like this game Marzia
You can beat Thanos in Star Wars
It's my favorite movie franchise. It is?
I thought you were- The story is a tragedy
Know what I love there. It is. Not a story. Okay, because I don't really know much about
Let's test how many minute Orient's we have? Okay
Oh
General Kenobi, wait was it general Kenobi? Yeah. Why is he a general?
Is that in that I
Was joking I was Joe Reddy's off no, I was joking. I'm watching them right now
Okay, I saw them I can't believe it have podracing now this is podracing
That's another one
How do we progress in this game can we trying how do we please this is YouTube
Okay, if you're gonna call ahead with me
You might say you are the most beautiful girl in the whole know
people wanted us to play Star Wars and this is just us an e-book to
Progress how the kids figure out how to get in. How do you do it? How did you do it?
How did you do it I use the pool
Okay
Do we just hit resume you quit wasn't me? No, it wasn't. No hey
I'm sorry
What did you do? Oh my CI I just got the car I
Can't do it Oh a surprise to be sure but a welcome one
A surprise to be sure but a welcome one, by the way
My said you are strong and white and I'm very proud of you you
Are strong and wise Anakin and I am very proud of
Oh
You are on this council, but we do not grant you the rank of Master what
I
Don't like sand it's coarse rough and irritating and it gets everywhere
Not like here here everything is soft
And smooth
Okay, I can do that
What is the matter Phoenix
Don't like sand
it scores
It's Rob. It's their routine
Then it gets everywhere
But not like here
Notlikethis
Better acting then the freak will explain me
Thank you so much Marcia for joining me on another adventure. This will be the first episode of
The whole thing. So if we if you felt like we didn't progress
Don't worry more is coming
Or it's coming. What did I say? The communications a disruption in the communications can mean only one thing
invasion
How does that relate a communications disruption can mean only one thing?
Invasion, you didn't like Star Wars you didn't like this video, right? But what you should do is
smack like
How long have you been doing?
this five hundred thousand likes and will do part to check out Marcia's channel and leave a link in the description and as always
Like the full spin